mais je voudrais vous demander de nous
expliquer d'abord ce qu'est le mécanisme
du jeu des mille francs et puis nous
parler un petit peu de des expériences
que vous avez eue pendant ces huit mois
à la havane itinérante vous vous êtes
aggloméré vous et qu'ils veulent ou rtf
à aux gens du voyage lui a je crois
qu'il faut expliquer aux auditeurs ou
téléspectateurs le déroulement
chronologique mais ce fameux jeu des
mille francs vous savez qu'il ya tout
d'abord un monsieur qui se cachent
d'alien qui se déguise à l'occasion pour
cacher cette fameuse enveloppe qui doit
être trouvée après la diffusion
d'énigmes 8,9 à carpentras elles nous
disent merci messieurs mais si vous
voulez bien avant
merci wc jeunesse à demain prochain
enregistrement du jeu de 1000 francs
donc aujourd'hui à montpellier sous le
grand chapiteau plein gré après
ouverture helmand alors attention
bandits pour les téléspectateurs des
mentalités langlade qui m'entourent voix
au contact était perdue aux alentours de
l'entrée principale du secteur vert.fr
montrer comment la coutumière de
l'envelope toutes les indications
nécessaires pour participer
angeli francs vous irez céder à ses
caractéristiques on arrive sur une
petite place désertines est absolument
personne et brusquement dès que l'énigme
a été diffusé vous apercevez des gens
arrivés de tous les coins de l'horizon
c'est un petit peu un film de rené clair
ou savez vous voyez cette place ce
peuple et des petits-enfants des grands
des personnes qui arrivent à bicyclette
en moto en automobile à fond de train
ayant en serrant très fort les fronts et
puis qui monte aux arbres qui dévalisent
quelquefois a eu une boutique qui
essaient quelquefois même deux
de chercher dans les roues pour voir où
cette fameuse enveloppe est caché il ya
même quelques fois on en arrive pas aux
mains mais si c'est tout juste prix
[Musique]
lorsque l'enveloppé trouvait en principe
je suis là et je redonne les premiers
conseils et nous les retrouvons ensuite
après la parade
car il faut bien l'appeler ainsi la
parade qui a lieu sur le quart de
propagande de la rtf et pendant ses
parades
je présente le trophée pinder ou rtf de
l'accordéon et je présente un petit jeu
pour les enfants toute une série de
questions qui s'adresse non seulement
aux petits mais au plus grand également
et je fais actuellement le jeu des
portraits il y a eu un interlude il ya
eu vive la vilenie beaucoup de jeux qui
ont se sont déroulés sur le cas de
propagande et à la fin de cette petite
parade qui a lieu sur ce quart du rtf je
vois les candidats dans un petit bureau
pour leur expliquer le déroulement du
jeu pour prendre un premier contact avec
eux et pour savoir s'ils sont si longs
intention d'aller très loin
ensuite le soir nous les convoque pour
8h30 ils reviennent dans un autre petit
bureau pour que monsieur muscle puisse
passer au survêtement de monsieur muscle
je le redis quelques mots et la fois il
entre en scène
et là vous savez ce qui se passe
attention seuls quarts 3-2
[Musique]
au cimetière un bris c'est que
l'amérique mène 7 qui est également la
patrie de l'argent rieur de georges
brassens il d'être champions
d'aujourd'hui qui paraîtra
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
thierry culliford monsieur eddy va
représenter donc aujourd'hui tous les
6,6 sétois et votre enfant des mureaux
presse ainsi vous suit expliquiez qui a
vu bien mort et vont dérouler et vous
essayer à clermont l'hérault
non j'en suis ni un revirement terrain
bon mais vous avez vite et qui à mon
sens dans l'oise
pour l'instant mon regret que quelque
chose allait bien je suis âgée relations
depuis longtemps et auparavant
auparavant socialement sa transmission
cvt de saison il faut dire que ce sont
des voisins qui fut se destine aux
professionnels c'est ce jeune homme qui
appelle à 20 ans
les sétois on essaie ça monsieur et que
paypal
je peux encore allons construire un
tissu orange est parti j'ai 3 74 cas et
je dois passer le prochaine les services
de chemin de lâcher six à dix neuf états
unis l'egypte ou de la vue car un vrai
challenge
durant sa vision que c'est ce qui compte
ce n'est quelques heures les parents
n'ont connu ni la tige de nouvelles
données
[Musique]
et peu de gens qui ont extorqué célèbre
négatif hébergées dans des campements
avec toi renfort qui n'a mis que
quelques pas à faire revenir au micro et
inonu n'ont d'ailleurs qu'un plan
exemple celle ci plaisir de nous on n'a
rien eux manche chagrin d'amour du
christ n'affiche que les lecteurs de ses
symboles je le sens confie t elle
comment qui lancent des parités
rayonnant c'était utile de le faire
c'est lui l'audient mais c'est le
dilemme après
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]